44 seconds of logos are you people not
paying attention or what also Comcast if
I don't see taillights in the next five
minutes Lee that audio is from a phone
call do they take hostage calls over
ISDN now because that was some
crystal-clear reception if these guys
had to rappel down this rock face to get
back here undetected how did the rocks
actual face get back here to hide
underneath this perfectly placed camo
shield most movies just read a line of
dialogue about how the rocks character
is former military or was previously an
NFL player this movie goes out of its
way to actually film that backstory and
I can't decide if I want to applaud it
or give it the finger wait
nope just made up my mind also this
opening a hostage situation handling
scene intended to give our main
character situational credibility for
later is giving me so many of the
negotiator vibes I'm this close to
crying foul yeah let's do it
[Music]
turn around where the hell was that kid
hiding that no one saw him until he
turned around was he tiny and just grew
really quickly is he part SeaMonkey is
he part SeaMonkey also why did he even
have him over there in the first place
so he hears them bust in and immediately
grabs a hostage and then turns around
and sets him on the counter what the
hell and it was like the movie I sure do
oh goody it's the rear double impossible
surprise turn around this time we are
supposed to buy that he's been holding
that detonator this whole time and that
no one noticed his shirt look bulky
before now either this movie is stupid
or these SWAT guys are stupid and I'll
give you one guess which two things I
think it is okay
Jesus this movie about a giant
skyscraper rescue will is probably
likely to be full of enough bull
coincidences without you Florence
Nightingale his love interest from the
Great Pyramid of Giza to the Tower of
Babel news raishin mankind has been
consumed by one singular desire to touch
the sky what about planes or spacemen we
sent men to the moon and I'm pretty sure
they touch the sky and then gave it the
finger as they blasted through it into
outer space I know you want to build up
your fucking skyscrapers some kind of
important thing but making super tall
buildings sound like one of man's
greatest longings it's just silly
going so far as to build a 30-story
physical park at the building center
sounds practical hey Timmy go along I
mean go deep wait that sounds wrong to
me get high oh that's not right either
hey Timmy let's just go to a regular
non-vertical Park what do you say this
isn't just another
building it's a building but for some
reason looks like a snake trying to eat
a tennis ball and also is located in
Hong Kong for structural reasons that
have absolutely nothing to do with the
international box office numbers the
post speaks to what we can achieve when
we don't accept limitation five Pirates
of the Caribbean movies and you dick OHS
still decide to call this thing up in
pearl we're gonna we look I know the
rock reached out to amputees and did
what he could to make this character
respectful and not an exploitation and I
know the movie probably can't get funded
and made if there's not a high-profile
action star attached but I'm still going
on the record that this feels wrong and
icky and at the very best super Google
is at I know but you should let me fix
your tie because apparently even though
you are a grown-ass man you can't tie
your own so that we can have an intimate
moment and build our relationship cliche
just because you're a smaller company
does not mean that you don't belong the
noise of all the tiny violins playing my
heart bleeds for thee for this truly
pitiable bastard here is deafening what
did I tell you to do anytime something's
wrong if I try turning it off and on
again try turning it off and on again
but when shadowy I teased Blaney this is
what a 30-story park looks like apart
with 30 stories of air above it thanks
for putting in a good word come on it's
nothing
movie could not be signaling this guy's
evilness more if he was wearing a black
hooded cape and carrying a side is this
movie sponsored by Scripps because it's
just spelling everything out one of the
reasons they don't actually build
buildings this tall in real life is that
if they did it'd be physically
impossible to have enough elevators to
serve the needs of the building's
tenants and anyone that's ever stayed in
a midtown Manhattan hotel that was
exactly what I'm talking about
the pearls anti-fire measures employ a
one-of-a-kind self sealing ventilation
system could God did the producers of
this movie think the phrase was tell
don't show considering this exposition
mission continues for quite some time
let's just add another 15 cents and move
on it's the safest super tall structure
in the world its Fort Knox mile in the
sky man what a great analogy I mean I
wouldn't trade that analogy for all the
golden no no no this is awkward
once I inspect the security at the
off-site facility my job will be done
which for some strange reason I didn't
do before having this very important
meeting today because reasons it's
incredible
I'm over there I just can't Irene do you
lose depth perception when you lose a
limb in what world would you actually a
mistake a projected image as a real
person it's maybe the single dumbest
thing I've seen in a movie this year and
I watched a freaking no movie that's
is comprised of nearly 25,000
ultra-high-definition panels I think I
speak for everyone when I say my welcome
to heaven mr. Sawyer and then he just
king left him there I haven't touched a
gun in ten years it's important to the
rock to play characters that don't
believe in violence he's on a boat but
we've also been told he's going directly
from a skyscraper to the off-site
monitoring facility just over a mile
away and we already saw that there is no
need to catch a ferry to make that trip
as roads will suffice the funny thing is
without that bad luck I never would have
met Sara I'm just gonna go out on a limb
and say if a wall collapses in the
sub-basement of the world's tallest
building I'd probably be pretty quick to
call someone and also probably get the
hell out of there instead of you know
slowly exploring it myself like some
sort of lame horror movie stooge armed
intruder pink jump scares man how the
pandas well we didn't really get to see
them because Henry ate a weird candy and
started throwing up King Henry did he
have an attack no he's breathing fine
son has asthma are you goddamn kidding
me with his I guess the daughter's
probably hypoglycemic and Sarah herself
has split ends or lymphoma or something
right this movie is all the hurdles
sarah is super suspicious about these
dudes but then does not call her husband
back immediately or anyone apparently
she just quit scary shot in the
prosthetic leg Aang this is just the
first of many times the movie will make
it convenient that its main character
has a prosthetic leg I guess some people
really will do anything to get a leg up
on the competition why is the dishwasher
even open to Hamza jaw here come back to
patch up roadblocks arm and then decide
to do some light housework I just want
to know because apparently knowing is
half the battle wasn't supposed to be
that so if Sydney and the chips off the
old rockier weren't even supposed to be
there why did they start the fire near
the floor they were staying on we only
needed the mask while dumping the
chemical but now that the chemical is
merely lying on the floor in piles we
won't be needing these anymore
that's a mess house on fire and you find
out what including those I know we've
seen plenty of corny Hiro one-liners
villains have their fair share of
stopping whatever they're doing to say
clever things as well I mean who's he
even talking to the buildings on fire
the building isn't on fire the 96th
floors on fire what an asshole what kind
of person takes things literally and out
of context when they obviously knew it
was intended just so they can make a
smart ass point that their subscribers
might think is funny wait what so
hold on if they had to scan his face to
get access to the tablet anyway what was
the plan if they had stolen it from him
on the boat when they've had to find him
anyway he is about to ride a motorcycle
run and otherwise get to the skyscraper
without once needed to cross water in a
ferry just FYI on so is the fire on a
floor right below them I'm so confused
there's probably some sort of
explanation for all this that I missed
when I fell asleep during all the
exposition but Mubi certainly doesn't
seem interested in clearing it up and
the more I learn the more that random
encounter with the bad guys seems more
and more convenient don't worry about
there and there's a lot of smoke a lot
about the Cat Stevens right this
dialogue just remember there's a lot of
smoke and it's hard to get by just upon
a smile huh so the fire is on 96 and the
rock band is on 98 but then answer me
this why did the bad guys encounter the
family on floor 98 when they were
setting the fire material on floor 96
why would they ever have even gone above
ninety six but needlessly blasted all
the employees here with machine guns
that fired into all these computers and
screens but apparently the one they need
to use went untouched seal all the fire
doors 95 to the ground disable all
energy fire mixtures from 96 to the top
why the plan was to gain full access to
the building all along why not just wait
until you had that access to even set
the fire in the first place what if
something goes wrong and you've blown
your plan by putting the fire before the
horse something also why even set it on
that floor if you want to cause an
evacuation at the penthouse why not set
the fire on the floor directly below it
and a building with that many stories it
seems the only one you care about is a
story about this family who has to
conveniently escape upwards as the fire
chases them tell me what you see you are
looking at it I was the point it's a
video call they survive this but only
because that's not how fire works good
thing the phone didn't break drop the
call or land face down or behind
anything or isn't blocked by smoke that
for some reason this fire doesn't create
cuz you know if you thought they were
dead there would be no reason for the
rock to continue to do more and more
ridiculous and implausible stunts to get
to them and the movie would be over god
forbid also that phone is absolutely
pointed at the ceiling and would never
in a million years shoot this angle is
he hearing the audio from this giant
building size TV across the street so
they just leave the volume on that thing
max down all the time or just when the
plot needs the police to hear some
information and become another
Ross was obstacle what's stupider that
these are the only two cops in this
super crowded area or that will is about
to Jason borne them on purpose because
he believes he's the only one that could
save his family on the cops will never
understand literally the only human on
the planet does that can practice yeah
it's pretty smart right I don't even
know anymore if this movie actually
wants to make sense and I would like to
leave now I like how he didn't encounter
any more cops between that busy
intersection in this construction site
and also no locks or security measures
at the ground level of this construction
site I think everyone has their my
family I'm getting out of here breaking
point and I'm just saying mine would
have been way before now huggies
presents pull ups the movie so here's
the idea the rock is gonna run
full-speed off a super crane while being
shot at and leap about fifty feet into a
window on the floor below it's going to
be a mix you have to be running like 20
miles an hour on a prosthetic leg to
even get close to making that job come
on it'll be in slow motion a hundred
stories up with the lit up Hong Kong
skyline behind him while he does that
whole running on the air flailing thing
only a barely grabbed on a piece of
metal and swing himself up by one who
will even care
cinemasins cares motherfucker cinemasins
cares you just knew the action would
bring our hero's family to the 30-story
tall Park you knew that when they showed
it to you it's basically check offs 30
story tall Park why would they stop
so is that the plan make a perfect shot
to kill the pilot who will for whatever
reason still be holding the controls
costing the chopper to run forward and
possibly kill everyone in its way that
seems likely a terrible shot this
assholes stormtrooper cousin disowned
him due to his horrible aim true story
dominated that system I can't open the
doors with this tablet you guys really
plan for everything didn't you got a
movement elect and my fancy tablet not
only has a camera that is immediately
following them and also identifies them
by name and also somehow hasn't been
destroyed by the fire or had its
visibility limited by any smoke
screwdrivers hammers vodka tape also
this movie is die hard meets towering
inferno meets the equalizer meets paint
firewall and all 22 people who saw fire
wall just exclaimed okay thank you
you can't fix with duct tape and sure
obvious diehard ripoff is obvious but I
at least feel like john-boy was human
and die hard when McLain walked barefoot
across the class you could feel the pain
if the rock did it in this movie he
would adjust the glass shards in the
bottom of his feet for maximum traction
and then run straight up a wall carving
his name in it along the way that's
right listen to your mommy
well technically their dad was a mummy
she's their mommy but I get the
confusion and the Scorpion King is
lingering around here somewhere but he
could have died in the fire when I say
things like the circumstances conspired
to keep her from her kids what I really
mean is this movie can suck my balls oh
come on just seconds after a convenient
piece of the building separates Sarah
from her kids a convenient burning tree
separates the siblings was this building
also built with a state of the art plot
device system gorgeous Esther Christ
this is a video game cutscene but not
only that one of those levels that takes
you like a hundred tries to beat it and
video games the rock holding the bridge
steady via two ropes while it supposedly
tries to collapse while his wife walks
the plank to retrieve their son is the
most rockingest thing Dwayne the rock
Johnson has ever done on film and it's
laughable this movie actively hates
physics also why send the wife to bring
the son why not just tell the son to
crawl across we're wasting time and
energy sending wild things over to carry
him back are we not but I gotta get you
guys out of this bill
Henry Henry King Henry I need you to be
brave right now you do that for me well
Dan I do have the chronic asthma
aggravated by the smoke and we're 130
stories into the sky and a building on
fire but if you think spouting cliches
at me is gonna help I'm happy to respond
in kind
unless the laws of inertia have been
revoked as fast as they drop they should
be slammed against the top of this
elevator with no way to reach that break
in time if you ask me this just seems
like a recipe for Campbell's soup I've
had televisions for a long time and I've
never once turned one on and had it tell
me something I needed to know about my
life but apparently this is the thing
because it happens for the rock every
day I'm Tom behind the turbines movies
ins itself the other script and then
Will's reaction to the script we had an
accent
Scandinavian I think six-foot white
muscular this is the man you saw me
buddhu witchcraft right here computers
can't even explain this just vague
description of every European ever then
we found him I've done the whole duct
tape hands thing that's most homeowners
half especially those with forecasts or
a spider problem the point is the
stickiness of that wears off in a matter
of seconds even though this movie is
going to give him Tom Cruise levels of
proverbial rope here we go again you
know what I'm sick of how flat-out
impossible everything is in this movie
so let's just speed this along shall we
this works this works this works this
works this works this works this works
this works one
this works this works this works this
works this works this works this works
this works and this works also Pearl Jam
what he didn't know was that I hit
traffic software and said know why you
tons of fun that's not how wire
transfers work this was my insurance
policy
and I kept it on an external hard drive
that looked like a Decepticon and would
barely fit in my pocket because
technology but Ethan gets his hands on
this he can reverse-engineer my tracking
software and hide their identities
before anyone's the wiser what's that
girl there's trouble down at the old
well let's go we lit this entire
building on fire knowing that you would
take the most valuable thing in this
world to you and run gives my headaches
headaches its information it's once and
zeros email that upload it to Dropbox
there was literally no reason to use an
oversize Iron Man flash drive is the
original hard copy of what is
essentially digital data you hacked a
wire transfer by the way and learn the
names of the crime syndicate bad guys
back is data Jesus jumpin Christ on a
lukewarm eggo waffle so what's the plan
got any duct tape oh you guys Total
Recall call and look Bing know they're
gonna have to get in line but they'd
still like to have a word about this
scene well this is fun and it's gonna
happen about 20 more times here and you
know what that means
go go go
the rocks wife who is a nurse will now
go toe to toe with the badass assassin
girl the movie has already basically
made out to be unkillable Oh for fuck's
sake tablet has been useless to the
assassin chicks since halfway through
the film when it couldn't get her
buddies into the penthouse why is she
even still carrying around for
assassinate duties all right you win
considering we all know that he's
actually right behind him I want you to
consider these things that DJ would be
talking to feet behind him and not be
hurt that he drops that gun right by
their feet that where is camera that
gets that clean of a picture without his
daughter and Kaptur blocking its view
that video glitch that only happens
after he gives away the twist and at him
giving away a buyer in no way gives him
any advantage he didn't already have and
that he almost certainly would have
kicked his daughter down this hole based
on where she was standing and if this
room they are in is basically a thousand
degree metal oven at this point and tell
me if you can think of any reason not to
give one of the most bull climaxes in
the history of film and extra sin for
every floor and this logic forsaken
building it's what it thought you bet
your fuckin ass I'm sending the fact
that she's able to reboot the fire
suppression system
Lee over-the-air in a building that is
90% on fire the only promise the movie
ever really had was knowing that this
giant ball was gonna fall off the top
and crash into the sea or onto the road
below
uh-uh nope movie is too stupid to even
give us that I'd remove all the sins if
one of these reporters or EMTs we're to
lift their head and reveal themselves to
be Vin Diesel okay no I wouldn't remove
the sits but that would still make this
movie way better which is saying
something
lucky bad thing I said to myself when
this movie finally ended somehow I made
it into the film just get in the car I
did burn some men just want to watch the
world burn my program seizes the phone
line of whoever's tracing me and jams
their modem so they can't hung up now
the hunted becomes the hunted you and I
will kill you there's one thing you
should know first
what yes
[Music]
that was easy